>> Jimmy: I'M SO HAPPY YOU'RE
HERE, AND THIS IS VERY, VERY
EXCITING NEWS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TELL
EVERYONE?
>> THIS SEASON 4 -- NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH, I AM HAVING A BABY.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
COME ON!
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: HI, BABY!
HI!
WELCOME TO "THE TONIGHT SHOW."
wow,THIS MUST BE SO EXCITING.
THIS IS YOUR FIRST BABY?
>> YEAH, IT IS.
I HAVE A STEPSON, BUT THIS IS
MY FIRST BABY THAT'S COME OUT
OF ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: HAS IT BEEN FUN
TELLING FAMILY AND FRIENDS?
>> IT HAS, BUT I'VE BEEN
OVERSEAS A LOT.
I'VE BEEN HERE.
SO, THERE'S A FEW PEOPLE THAT
I -- BEFORE THE PREMIERE LAST
NIGHT, I WAS LIKE, "OH MY GOD,
EVERYONE'S GOING TO KNOW IN A
A MOMENT THAT I'M PREGNANT, AND
THERE'S SOME PEOPLE I HAVEN'T
TOLD."
SO, MOM, DAD --
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO --
>> Jimmy: YOU HAVEN'T TOLD MOM
AND DAD?
>> NO, NO, FRIENDS AND OTHER
PEOPLE THAT I HAVEN'T HAD A
A CHANCE TO GET ON THE PHONE
WITH.
>> Jimmy: SOMETHING'S
HAPPENING.
THIS IS GREAT NEWS, YEAH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
SO HAPPY YOU'RE HERE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT "SUCCESSION,"
THIS IS SEASON 4.
THIS IS THE FOURTH AND FINAL
SEASON.
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: DID YOU KNOW THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO BE THE FINAL
SEASON?
>> NOT DURING -- LIKE, NOT
DEFINITIVELY.
WE FOUND OUT AT THE END, AT THE
TABLE READ FOR 410, SO, THE
LAST EPISODE.
AND DURING THE SHOOTING IT WAS
LIKE, "WILL WE, WON'T WE, I
DON'T KNOW."
AND THEN BY THE TIME WE GOT TO
THE END IT WAS LIKE, "JUST
BREAK UP WITH US ALREADY, ARE
YOU GOING TO TELL US?"
>> Jimmy: YEAH, EXACTLY.
>> WE'RE STOPPING, AND YEAH,
AND WE ARE.
>> Jimmy: YOU ARE, YEAH.
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: ANY ROOM TO KEEP THE
DOOR OPEN AT ALL?
>> OH, I MEAN, WHEN I READ THE
FIRST --
WHEN I FIRST READ THE SCRIPT, I
DIDN'T ACTUALLY GET A CHANCE TO
READ IT UNTIL ARRIVING AT THE
TABLE READ.
SO I WAS LIKE, QUICKLY, LIKE,
READING THE LAST COUPLE PAGES
IN THE CAR ON THE WAY, AND FELT
VERY MUCH LIKE, "YEAH, THIS IS
THE END."
AND HAD A BIT OF A CRY IN THE
CAR, AND I ARRIVED WITH, LIKE,
TEAR-STREAKED FACE.
AND I'M LIKE, "IT'S OVER."
>> Jimmy: WOW.
>> AND MATTHEW WAS LIKE, "OH, I
DON'T THINK SO.
NO, I THINK --"
[ LAUGHTER ]
"NO, I THINK THAT'S VERY
HOPEFUL."
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: THE INTERNET HAS ALL
SORTS OF FAN THEORIES,
BECAUSE -- JUST BASED ON THE
POSTER, BECAUSE THIS IS THE
SEASON 3 POSTER.
AND EVERYONE WAS LIKE, "AH, WHO
IS BEHIND WHO?
IN THE POSTER THAT KIND OF --
MAYBE THAT'S A LITTLE
SOMETHING."
THEN I THOUGHT MAYBE THE FINAL
SEASON, COULD THERE BE EASTER
EGGS IN THIS POSTER HERE?
>> OH.
>> Jimmy: HAVE YOU SEEN THIS
POSTER?
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: ARE THERE EASTER EGGS
IN IT?
>> THE -- I --
[ LAUGHTER ]
I MEAN, A LITTLE, YEAH.
YEAH, THERE'S LIKE --
>> Jimmy: REALLY?
>> YEAH, THERE IS.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
BUT I FEEL LIKE YOU WON'T KNOW
UNTIL YOU KNOW.
>> Jimmy: OH.
>> IT'S LIKE "THE DA VINCI
CODE," YOU'RE SORT OF LIKE
PUTTING THINGS TOGETHER.
BUT THERE IS -- THERE IS A
A THING THAT ONCE THE SEASON
BEGINS AIRING, IT MAY GET
RELATED BACK TO THIS MOMENT.
>> Jimmy: I'LL TAKE IT.
[ AUDIENCE OOHS ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
I WILL TAKE IT.
WE JUST HAD JENNIFER ANISTON ON
THE SHOW.
HAVE YOU GUYS EVER MET BEFORE?
>> NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT I'M A BIG FAN.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, ME TOO, WE'RE
ALL FANS.
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: FREAKING OUT, RIGHT?
>> WE GREW UP WITH -- YEAH.
>> Jimmy: I WAS JUST THINKING,
LIKE, IF THE CAST OF "FRIENDS"
WERE ANYTHING LIKE THE CAST --
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER AND CHEERS ]
-- OF "SUCCESSION," WHO WOULD
BE WHO?
>> OH.
OH.
UM, I MEAN, I FEEL LIKE GREG
HAS GOT TO BE PHOEBE.
RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: OKAY.
OKAY.
>> YEAH, I THINK SO.
AND THEN -- AND KENDALL IS
ROSS.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: WHY?
>> 'CAUSE HE'S SAD.
HIS SAD FACE.
>> Jimmy: HE HAS SAD FACE,
YEAH.
>> HE'S LIKE REAL SAD.
>> Jimmy: SAD ALL THE TIME.
>> LIKE, SERIOUS SAD FACE.
HE'S LIKE, "OH, OH."
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> UM, AND THEN, LIKE, SHIV IS
MONICA, 'CAUSE SHE'S GOT HER
[ BLEEP ] TOGETHER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OR SHE'S GOT HER STUFF
TOGETHER.
CHANDLER'S ROMAN, THEN.
JOEY IS TOM, AND THEN LOGAN IS
RACHEL.
>> Jimmy: WOW, LOGAN'S RACHEL?
>> YEAH, YEAH.
THE WORLD, YOU KNOW, REVOLVES
AROUND --
>> Jimmy: YEAH, THERE -- ALL
RIGHT, GOOD.
>> IT'S LIKE IT TURNS ON AN
AXIS.
>> Jimmy: ALL RIGHT, I'LL TAKE
THAT.
SEASON 4 PREMIERES ON SUNDAY,
WHAT SHOULD PEOPLE KNOW GOING
INTO THIS?
>> OH, I MEAN, PROBABLY WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE LAST FOUR --
THREE SEASONS.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: NO, BUT IF YOU
HAVEN'T SEEN IT, IF YOU JUST
WANT TO HOP RIGHT IN.
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> AS A FAMILY, THEY REALLY GET
ALONG WITH EACH OTHER.
THEY LOVE EACH OTHER SO MUCH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THERE'S NOT A CONFLICT IN IT AT
ALL.
YEAH, YEAH, JUST BIG HUGS ALL
AROUND.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: SOMEONE'S TRYING TO
TAKE OVER --
>> YES.
>> Jimmy: -- THE BUSINESS.
>> YEAH.
WHO'S GOING TO WIN?
>> Jimmy: AND EVERY CHARACTER
IS SO WELL ACTED AND SO WELL
PLAYED THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
LOVE THIS THING.
>> YEAH, DEFINITELY.
>> Jimmy: ALL RIGHT, I WANT TO
SHOW A CLIP.
HERE'S SARAH SNOOK IN
"SUCCESSION."
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> ARE YOU SNAKING?
>> WE HEAR THAT YOU'VE BEEN
TAKING TO THE JIMENEZ
TRANSITION TEAM.
>> WELL, NO.
>> OH, NO?
>> NO.
>> NO?
OKAY, SO IT'S LIES THAT OUR
FRIEND TOLD US, THEY'RE LYING
TO US?
>> OH, I'VE TALKED TO THEM, BUT
IT'S BECAUSE I'M HELPING THEM
OUT, AS YOU ALREADY KNOW.
>> OKAY, SO YOU ARE TALKING?
>> NO, I RETURNED A CALL.
THEY WANT TO, YOU KNOW, TALK
ABOUT TALKING.
>> OH, THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
TALKING.
>> WHAT?
COME ON, THEY HAVEN'T WON THE
ELECTION, AND THEY MIGHT NOT,
AND DAD MIGHT NOT SELL, AND YOU
TWO MIGHT BAIL, AND IT'S A
A MAYBE, MAYBE, MAYBE,
SITUATION.
>> Jimmy: YES, IT'S SO FUN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
SARAH SNOOK, EVERYONE.
SEASON 4 OF "SUCCESSION"
PREMIERES THIS SUNDAY ON HBO
AND HBO MAX.